I realized before I froze my eggs there
was just this constant inner monologue
that was like is this the guy you're
gonna be with if not you have to move on
to someone else and I felt like I had to
accomplish all my professional goals by
the time I was like 35 it was just in
the back of my mind all the time like
I'd be in traffic and I feel like you
guys let's go I'm robbing from the
inside we got a bow okay
uterus is molding oh I feel like you
guys will never understand that pressure
because you guys don't have that clock
guys can have kids as late as they want
Clint Eastwood had a kid at like 70
years old
Robert De Niro had one at like 68 which
is so weird to me the idea of having a
kid it's 68 years old that's like being
like I really want a kid but only for
like ten years and I want to be deaf for
most of it that's I'm so glad I did it
it took all this pressure off like I
used to be the stress case now I'm just
chilling man
so easy like my agent calls me up he's
like where's that script I'm like I
don't know I'm high as fuck Paul Sarah
Silverman or some shit man cuz I'm
watching Game of Thrones again today hey
camera
oh thank you you freeze your eggs for a
couple of reasons if you want to
postpone having kids also if you want to
get a surrogate at some point which I'm
kind of obsessed with the idea of
getting a surrogate it's like you hire a
woman to carry your kid for you which I
really want to do at some point but I
feel kind of guilty about that idea
because when you get a surrogate you're
essentially like asking another woman to
do your dirty work for you it's like
worse than a guy getting a hooker
because when you get a hooker you guys
just want to use a woman's body for an
hour I want to use it for nine months
and totally wreck it I'm literally gonna
destroy that shit nice I just feel like
I would like my kids so much more if I
didn't carry my kid it makes sense like
I totally support those toddler and
t-ara moms I think those kids should
work I think they should have to
tap-dance to pay for all the damage they
did to those poor women although I feel
like if you have a surrogate have your
kid you can't control the kid as well
you know like the way my mom used to
guilt me into doing things she'd be like
I carried you for nine months I'd be
like yeah that's a good point but if
like I had a surrogate what am I gonna
say I'm gonna be like I had to drive ten
minutes to pick you up traffic was a
nightmare
yeah it's not as good when you freeze
your eggs the doctor asks you if you
want to get a donor like a sperm donor
because if you want to freeze embryos
you know like basically if you freeze an
embryo that means a sperm fertilizes the
egg and I was like I don't have any
sperm available in my house at the
moment
so he's like maybe you should get a
donor and I wasn't really ready for that
but I got super obsessed with the kind
of person who would become a sperm donor
so I went online and I was like on the
donor site you'd think that sperm donors
for complete losers not true in order to
be a sperm donor you have to be at least
five eight I was like I'm sorry what
shallow bitch was 45 years old not
married no options goes into the sperm
bank is like oh five seven never mind
I'm gonna get on FarmersOnly and take my
chances
fuck that weirdo Ben shit and an order
is important order you have to have at
least four years of college I was like I
don't want my sperm donor to have four
years of college because if you have
four years of college and you're jerking
off into a cup for $100 you're a drug
addict and if you don't have four years
of college and you're jerking off into a
cup for a hundred dollars you're an
entrepreneur and I like your hustle